[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est une âme écoute vraiment tu fais
bien chez moi je pense qu'elle en terme
de non mais c'est vrai tu vois ça y est
il est bien sage il est bien lui il fait
bien ça chacun dont dans sa façon qu il
s altérer ds wii fait bienvenu le bien
ça écrème oui l'amour tout le monde on
se bat non pas du tout mais pas moi
voilà je suis pris mon coeur est pris
mais s'il était libre je foncerai comme
un gant et c'était sûr et bien c'est
christina vous dit il peut se passer
quelque chose
est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être vous
libérer comme un taxi à des 20 heures
[Applaudissements]
il manque un peu de jeu s'est bonifié le
jeu peut-être un peu trop tard août nous
ce n'est pas très moderne j'aurais fait
un rafraîchissement niveau coiffure wavy
et le jean est un peu plus un peu mais
qui peut-être un peu plus brute nous
quelques brutes à venir
[Rires]
[Musique]